y neumáticos ardiendo a lo largo de la
frontera entre israel y la franja de
gaza las protestas en contra del bloqueo
israelí sobre el sitiado enclave
volvieron a derivar en violencia con el
lanzamiento de granadas aturdidoras y
gases lacrimógenos para disuadir a los
cientos de congregados un joven
palestino murió por disparos del
ejército israelí y hay más de 15 heridos
entre ellos varios menores de edad
estábamos cerca de la frontera quemamos
algunos neumáticos mis primos estaban
conmigo nos dispararon gas lacrimógeno
hasta ahora nos están lanzando gases
lacrimógenos y me ahogue debido al gas
pero volveré de nuevo a dejar ya se
trata de la sexta noche consecutiva de
manifestaciones lideradas por el grupo
unidad de confusión nocturna afín a
hamás las fuerzas de seguridad de israel
justificaron el uso de munición real
alegando que los manifestantes estaban
lanzando artefactos explosivos
israel mantiene a los más de 2 millones
de palestinos que viven en gaza bajo el
bloqueo desde que el grupo hamas se hizo
con el control del territorio en 2007 y
si bien israel aprobó el miércoles una
serie de medidas para aliviar las
restricciones a la franja como la
reapertura del único cruce comercial
kerem shalom para muchos nada ha
cambiado
todas las facilidades que israel dice
haber concedido a la franja de gaza
existían antes de la reciente guerra el
número de comerciantes que iban a israel
antes del último conflicto era de siete
mil hoy tres meses después de la guerra
israel establece este número a siete mil
los desmanes de la frontera recuerdan a
las masivas marchas de 2018 cuando los
gazatíes iniciaron un movimiento de
protesta para exigir el fin de la
asfixia económica israelí y el derecho
de los palestinos a regresar a sus
tierras